many rumors have been suggesting at the
gtx 1180 will be a lot more expensive
than 10 series but is that actually true
[Music]
welcome to Haris hobbies so starting off
many people are suggesting that the GTX
leavener series will be a lot more
expensive than the 10 series because
nvidia still has a lot of inventory of
10 series so they are suggesting that in
video price the eleventh series higher
in order for it just don't make sense to
buy the 10 series after the 11 series
comes out but here's the thing Nvidia is
already getting rid of their inventory
as soon as possible by offering you
really great discounts all the 10 series
which are going on right now we're
seeing prices that we've never seen
before for example right now you can get
a GTX 1080 for four hundred and forty
five dollars so clearly there is no need
to price the GTX at 1180 at a price
range of 800 to 1000 dollars for it
still makes sense to buy the GTX 1080
the GTX 1180 can simply come up for the
same MSRP s of GT x 1080 at 7:00 or
dollars and it would still make sense to
buy both cars
besides by now NVIDIA has most likely
already sold all their 10 series cards
to retailers so it's not even their
problem anymore so they would much
rather prefer to boost the sales of the
eleven series instead of ensuring okay
or good sales on a 10 series close the X
is the inventor of the 10 series has
already led to delay in the launch of
the 11 part series so I doubt they're
going to delay it and overpriced the 11
series in order to get rid of tensors
inventory they have already postponed
the launch of the 11 or series by a
month and I think that was enough for
them to get rid of all that extra
tensors inventory by offering really
great discounts on them so there's
really no need for them to price it so
high secondly many of you guys are
suggesting that that new GT dr6 memory
will increase the cost to the 11 or
series because of the difference in
price between GT dr6 and GDR 5x + 5
memory now this is a valid point but it
is not going to lead to massive price
hikes there may be a little premium
across the board for the 11 room series
or the 10 series may be up to $50 but it
is not going to be crazy hi and I really
doubt that it'll be over $50 premium
next it's being suggested that Nvidia
will run our stock of the 11 Series
right as it launches because of all the
demand from the 11 her series and that
price will increase because of that well
here's the thing
Nvidia already delayed the launch of the
11 Series by one month because of the
X's inventor of the 10 series and plus
rumor suggests that GPU on to production
which is what they use for 10 series
cards already stopped way back in
February so they have had more than
enough time to produce enough cards to
meet market demand and Nvidia definitely
knows how much hype is surrounding the
1100 series so if the 11 Series still
goes out of stock it really was on
purpose by Nvidia in order to get more
hype surrounding the 11 her series to
make it seem like it's hard to get
hopefully Amelia doesn't do that but
even if they did and we were seeing
stock your shoes it wouldn't be as bad
as you may think
for example the 8700 ka launched for an
MSRP of 370 dollars and there was
instantly stock issues and this led the
price to go up to 400 $15 so a little
over 10% increase and plus this is only
temporary and it came back to $307 just
two months after its release so really
it would just be a temporary increase in
the price for a little bit of time and
then I'll return back to normal a lot of
you guys definitely like to see the
review videos of these cards before
buying them so hopefully by the time
that you are ready to buy this issue has
completely subsided so if the gtx 1100
series comes out next month
just like expected and we're seeing
stock issues then they will definitely
be rectified by the holiday season of
this year and the holiday season is
pretty much the best time to buy a GPU
and we shouldn't be seeing any problems
right there finally many of you guys are
suggesting that Nvidia will prank the 11
or Series a lot higher than the 10
series because they have no competition
from AMD and they really have monopoly
right now but just because they have a
monopoly doesn't mean that they can
price it however they want because no
competition doesn't mean that people are
going to spend more on a GPU instead
those opt for lower-level GPU and
lower-level GPU screws
Crawford for NVIDIA and as a result at
the end it really wouldn't benefit them
for example let's say the Nvidia made
$30 for every 1150 days old and 50
dollars for every 11 safety they sold
they definitely make a lot more money
than that but this is just for example
sakes so let's say 500 people bought
1160 then Nvidia would make $25,000 now
let's say that they increase the price
of the GTX and lemon 60 by 40 percent
now they would be making $7 per unit
however a lot of people will now not be
able to afford to G tickets 1160 and
most people actually offer for the GTX
of 1150
they sell 40% price increases quite a
bit so now they'll get 300 people who
opt to buy it 1150 and only 200 people
who quote with 1160 300 times 30 plus
200 times 70 would come out to 23,000
dollars they're actually making less
money here clearly it is not that simple
and there's a lot more factors to
consider however in the end the same
principle applies by pricing mid-level
cards higher they are really not going
to make down much more money plus in the
long run this type of pricing scheme
would affect brand loyalty and make them
seem greedy so I really doubt that
Nvidia is going to do that so overall
considering all of that in my opinion I
do not think the 11 her series will be
over $50 more than their 10 series
counterparts but that's just what I
think what do you guys think how much do
you think the 11 or series cards will
cost and do you think it's worth it
make sure comment down below what you
guys think because I do it all my
comments time and curious as to what you
guys think - make sure to post your
thoughts also if you guys like sphere
then make sure drop a like and consider
subscribing if you like to see more
videos just like this one but until then
I'm Hari I'll see you guys on the next
one
[Music]